chers amis il faut battre le fer pendant
qu'il est chaud euros pour sûr mais chat
échaudé craint l'eau froide
allons à coeur vaillant rien
d'impossible
je pense plutôt qu'à l'impossible nul
n'est tenu
évidemment si vous le prenez comme ça au
royaume des aveugles les borgnes sont
rois
mais on ne fait pas d'omelette sans
casser d'oeufs
il faut se méfier car le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien ainsi
olalala là haut c'est affreux sabrina
sabrina geof sabrina au barça qu'à se
mastique azimi c'est après que ça il se
prépare pour prendre à mme henri ben
mais tu trembles et de père que se
passe-t-il de si grand monsieur du snob
mais le facteur veulent battre un chat
borgne et va bien dans l'eau froide avec
du fer pour faire une omelette et sans
casser son coeur échaudés et c'est
horrible est ce que tu me racontes là ça
me paraît bien incroyable où je t'assure
c'est vrai je viens de les entendre
écoute tu va raconter ça à france soir
il sera mieux que moi ce qu'il y à faire
oui françois françois bien be a long non
qu'est ce qui se passe encore j'arrive
casimir ouhlala bah dites dont vous avez
l'air bien agitée tous les deux casimir
me raconte une histoire à laquelle je le
comprends rien mais tu pourra sans doute
faire quelque chose j'ai pas je l'essayé
l'asie casini articule points eh bien
monsieur du snob et le facteur veux le
battre
un chat vaillant dans l'eau froide avec
du fer mais même s pour faire une
omelette mais sans casser son coeur est
chaude et j'ai compris j'ai compris du a
dit d'abord chat aux froides et chaudes
et moins ses cadres le pauvre chars et
ensuite tu as dit battre et c'est au ces
en rimes c'est horrible et après de
terminer avec vaillance et coeur mais
c'est rien manger casimir sais rien tu
sais je veux dire le facteur et monsieur
du snob se parlaient en citant des
proverbes des coins des proverbes
on dit aussi des maximes les proverbes
ce sont des phrases devenues très
populaires dont on se sert pour exprimer
certaines idées arc
j'ai rien compris aurait donné des
exemples du comprendra
je viens avec moi la prive de nine
isabelle olivier nier quoi rien tient
tous un petit peu dur mais sa place vous
savez ce que c'est des proverbes 1 vous
avez écouté les explications que j'ai
donné à casey mais là ce qu'il y en a
qui connaissent des proverbes olivier
nom il s'appelle chat échaudé craint
l'eau froide
je me donne une explication
oui prenons de chat par exemple le
rachat qui se promènent et on les jette
une gamelle d'eau froide d'eau chaude
par dont on jette une gamme et d'eau
chaude sur le corps la prochaine fois la
prochaine fois qu'on dû avoir de l'eau
même si elle est froide et hop il a
cavalé au vent ben la voilà à travers
yves tel père tel fils tel père tel fils
qu'est-ce que venir à dire que le fils
est pareil que le père c'est ça par
exemple s'il terre et coléreux et bien
on peut imaginer que le fils sera
coléreux la même chose
oui mais tu sais qu'avec des proverbes
qui se contredisent entretenir et
nakiele quelque chose et l'on se dit
exactement le contraire partant tel père
tel fils y en a huit mois je connais dit
le contraire qu'est-ce que ça ce
proverbe
l'appareil s'était va fils prodigue donc
un père peut être avare et le fils par
réaction raid prolixe et dire qu'il est
très généreux pour ne pas faire comme
son père justement d'autres exemples de
proverbes denis dit rien du tout je suis
un casino alors denis et moi je vous en
donner un
au royaume des aveugles les borgnes sont
rois
explications j'ai par exemple dans votre
classe admettons mon les très mauvais et
puis olivier est un petit peu meilleur
que les autres un autre c'est lui le
premier que ça veut pas dire pour ça
qu'il est très très fort contre et j'ai
tout à fait compris d'y avoir magazine
il a fait d'autres à coeur vaillant rien
d'impossible
alors yves legrand
à coeur vaillant naples aussi et encore
quelqu'un qui veut vraiment quelque
chose
il ira fera toujours présente un
alpiniste si je monte en haut d'une très
haute montagne car ce nom quand je
m'étais il a tellement de volonté il va
y arriver à cause de sa volonté
entendu il y en a d'autres encore à
lyonnais qu'il est exactement contraire
d'ailleurs c'est à l'impossible nul
n'est tenu
mais c'est à dire que par exemple les
viégeois demande de me donner des
proverbes
puis il n'en donne pas bien même si je
lui demande lui de monju demande
il n'arrivera pas abandonné bon ben je
crois que comme ça casimir devra avoir
compris oui oui tu as écris moi
maintenant je voudrais une chose puisque
nous voulons rien je voudrais pouvoir
rire avec tu vas corée - query et tout
ce qu'on a pu voir les bus couvrir les
abel s'est plutôt bien tout prix mais
aujourd'hui pourquoi vouliez du corps
excuser parce que maintenant c'est à moi
de rire parce qu'à ira bien qui rira le
dernier
mais bienvenu